(mysterious music)
(footsteps)
(buzzing)
- [Interviewer] Do you experience any PTSD
from your time at the CIA?
- I have nightmares, sure.
Flashbacks.
- So how did that translate into the work
you're actually doing?
- I can't talk about
operational work, so--
I don't think it really,
I don't think there's
really a way to answer
that without talking about shifting from
this kind of work to that kind of work,
do you know what I mean?
- Are there things you can talk about?
- When you leave the agency you go through
a long process of having
your cover rolled back.
And I'm able to talk
about having worked there
but obviously not the details of any
particular operation.
(footsteps)
(city noises)
(mysterious music)
In my early twenties
I created an algorithm
to predict areas in the world that would
give rise to terrorist activity.
I wanted to deconstruct what it is
that creates terrorism.
Spending years in another
country where nobody
knows what you do or who you really are
is lonely.
I mean it's lonely in the small moments
really as much as the big moments.
You can't really have honest or frank
conversation even in your own home.
Because of surveillance
and being listened to
and watched.
(waves crashing)
(exploding)
I did see things that I'll
never be able to un-see.
(urgent talking in foreign language)
Humans not seeing the
humanity in other humans.
(urgent talking in foreign language)
(gunshots)
Whether that's torture
or killings that are
undertaken with the
same kind of callousness
as a butcher might take
to a piece of meat.
(waves crashing)
(light music)
Is there a coyote in here?
You have snuggy dreams?
- Yeah.
(giggling)
- Wanna get some breakfast?
- Okay.
- Okay, let's go.
There you go.
As a parent, is my greatest responsibility
to go out and make the world a more safe
and peaceful place for
my daughter to inherit.
Or is it to be at home snug with her
reading Harry Potter and the world
she inherits be damned.
Hey, John, it's Amaryllis.
Were you able to get the Kurdish authority
on the phone about the date change?
I'm a little worried
with all the build up around Mosul.
I wanna make sure we're de-conflicting
with the Iraqi military.
Yeah, try DC and give me a ring back.
Okay.
I've created an organization called
Operation Zoë.
Zoë meaning life and also being
my daughter's name.
I wanted to take former military officers
and intelligence officers
who've all learned
very specialized skills
in order to wage war
and allow them to use
those specialized skills
in order to wage peace.
George, hi, my friend.
I would love to see you.
Nobody's Kurdish is like your Kurdish.
I think we're gonna have at least a night
in Erbil and we'll stay at the Rotana
'cause their security is amazing
and their security team
is trained by US Forces.
They've got double blast walls,
snipers on the roof,
so I feel pretty good about that.
But you could meet us there.
(speaking foreign language)
I think one of the greatest lessons
that I took away from
my career at the agency
is this underlying truth
that everybody believes
they are the good guy.
And for many people in Syria and Iraq
and Pakistan and Yemen and Somalia
and other places where
we're flying drones.
The idea of being kept safe by American
sky robots that kill people without
making a sound is as upsetting and driving
as much desire for conflict
in the Islamic world
as the atrocities that
we see Isis committing
is driving in the American world.
(birds chirping)
(footsteps)
(speaking foreign language)
Do you know what (foreign language) means?
- [Zoë] What?
- Heaven or the sky.
I travel so frequently
but it's never routine.
It's the minute that you find it routine
that you stop being aware and stop
taking precautions when
you're on the ground.
And you're gonna have
the most amazing week.
And I will see you when I get home.
I love you so, so, so, so much.
- Bye.
- I'll talk to you tonight.
- Okay.
- Bye, my love.
Bye.
(waves crashing)
(slow music)
My sweetest coyote,
More than anything, I
wish I could hold you
as you read this.
Wish I could wrap you up in my arms
and tell you how you're my best friend
and wisest teacher.
I wish I could read you
this snugged in our bed
with the world at bay outside our window
and only love around us.
But I'm writing you this
letter in case I can't.
In case I've been stopped
or hurt or killed.
In case it's only my love and not my arms
that hold you tonight.
(intense music)
(gunshots)
(yelling)
(radio static)
- [Officer] Engage, engage.
(speaking in foreign language)
(heavy breathing)
I want to explain why
I've put myself in danger.
Why I've risked a lifetime
of telling stories
with you in the park.
As you grew deep beneath my navel,
I felt all of humanity inside you.
The truth is all over
this tiny speck in space.
We humans are the same.
Craving of love, of understanding,
of being heard and seen.
Can we just go to
SFO International Terminal, please?
(wind blowing)
Things can change in a heartbeat.
You don't know who is
manning the checkpoint.
In some cases they are manned by
the Iraqi military and other cases by
extremist groups who
are operating locally.
Checkpoint Three.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Passenger] Yes, I have my passport.
- Mine's in the trunk,
can we open the trunk?
Oh, I stay here?
(speaking foreign language)
Okay, we'll pull over.
He's speaking in Kurdish.
We'll get out and grab our ID for him.
(mysterious noises)
(light music)
The aim of this trip is to spend time
with Syrian and Iraqi
young people who have
all lost family to the fighting and have
put together reconciliation programs to
build trust with one another again.
(speaking foreign language)
To be in the energy of
these kids who've seen
such savagery and just so much passion
and intellectual
curiosity about what it is
they can do to make sure that this doesn't
happen again on their watch.
At least in their country,
at least for their generation.
They are committed to peace.
(waves crashing)
We're ten years plus into one narrative
about the war on terrorism.
And it's very binary.
What we're doing is not bringing an end
to this conflict.
Ever since I was little I've really loved
this Rumi poem.
Out beyond ideas of
wrongdoing and right doing.
There is a field.
I'll meet you there.
(light music)
I love that idea,
because the more that
I was out in the field,
the more I realized that
the question is almost
always not who is right and who is wrong.
Almost always both sides
are partially right
and it's important for us to be able
to put ourselves in our adversaries shoes
and invite them to put
themselves in our shoes
so that we understand what is driving
this conflict or it goes on forever.
(light music)
Every single person that you meet
is made out of star stuff.
And so are you.
- What a beautiful night it is.
With the stars up in the dark night sky.
All the people turning out the lights
and settling down.
All flowers tucked under the dirt asleep.
The city is going to sleep.
What a beautiful night it is.
- I'm with you now as you read this.
And always in every breath.
Do not fear the darkness.
You have in your heart
the brightest of lanterns.
Let your love fill you with warmth,
that you might fill others,
and they still others,
until the world is lit from your heart.
You are the love of my life.
Your momma.
(mysterious music)
(light music)